grab your hammers and unleash your snake
it's time for ragnarok season two yes
it's been more than a year since this
show came completely out of the blue
with a different more modern take on
norse mythology if you want a little bit
of a catch-up i do have a season one
ending explained which i'll leave in the
description
below but if not be prepared to get
swept up in the town of etta just be
sure not to drink the water that damn
doodle industries has poisoned it but
before we begin
make sure to like and subscribe
seriously only eight percent of you are
subbed
it'll help me pay for my norwegian
lessons because god knows i'll need help
pronouncing gunu gugube
mountains unlike season one which
largely centered around our protagonist
magna learning that he is thor
season two has a new focus forge thor's
hammer mjolnir in order to defeat
the giants that's the main conflict of
ragnarok a show named after the final
battle between gods and giants which
will eventually lead to the end of the
world the util family are the last
remaining giants and
giants want to sow as much chaos in the
world as possible as opposed to the gods
who want law in order
the utils own norway's fifth largest
company and use it to pollute and poison
the town's drinking water
in fact when the company is exposed for
this along with tax evasion they
actually threaten to move
all their jobs to china if they're
reprimanded and the government actually
backs down just goes to show you how
corrupt the utils and the government is
fighting against this corruption is
magna who has teamed up with other gods
like voltan aka odin
imon aka freya a dwarf named halver and
harry the war god tier
this was outlined in the velespa
prophecy a prophecy which depicts the
end of the world
also being the name of the town ragnarok
is set there's just one
problem magna has lost his power in
episode three
magna kills the patriarch of the giants
of vidar who happens to be his
half-brother lortz's real father yeah it
starts to get a bit complicated this
causes a rift between the two to the
point
magna denounces his chosen one status
and losing his powers couldn't come at a
worse time in old norse tradition it is
up to the sun to avenge the father
so fiore having the power of the giants
sets his eyes on killing magna fiore
also ends up taking over util industries
something his sister
saxa resents since she wanted that
position but we'll get more into that
later but even without his powers magna
decides to join the team into breaking
into util industries in search of the
eternal fire
the only flame that can forge mjolnir
the weapon which will defeat the giants
in the battle of ragnarok in order to
craft mjolnir they'll need a few things
a feather head and spear tip from the
old world and a dwarf to forge it
the feather is what gives the hammer its
ability to fly and return
back to thor harry who is really the
embodiment of the war god tear is the
muscle fighting off fjord and getting
his hand chopped off in the process
in norse mythology tyr only has one hand
the other having been ripped off by the
wolf fenrir magda's ability to gain
access to the flame wouldn't have been
possible if it weren't for his brother
lords
lords was given the key to the warehouse
by saxa who at this point in the story
really hates her family for ousting her
as president of util industries
saxon never knew that lords would end up
giving the key to magna and magna even
lied to lawrence about what he was going
to do with it
you can see it gets a little bit
complicated magda lies to lorite saying
he needs the key to impress a girl
sidney telling him that he plans to hang
a big fu to util industry sign he knows
he can't tell his brother the truth that
he's about to forge a weapon that will
kill his biological family and could
potentially kill loritz himself
lawrence arguably has one of the biggest
emotional arcs this season an arc which
sets him up as the trickster god loki
at the beginning of the season lorettz
learns that his mother had an affair
with vedar making him the son of a giant
and half brother to magna this puts him
in a difficult position because his
biological dad is a giant and is half
brother
a god who does he side with and things
get more complicated when it seems
everyone around him betrays him
including bran who tries to kill him
this sets him up perfectly as loki as
you're never really sure what side he's
on or what trick he has up his sleeve
and if things weren't crazy enough lortz
injects himself with odin's blood in
norse mythology odin and loki were blood
brothers who swore a blood oath making
loki truly unique in this way loki
really becomes
half god half giant the implications of
this haven't been fully realized in the
show just yet
lord's journey this season also sees him
give birth to jormungandr
or the midgard serpent in norse
mythology it is said this serpent grew
so large it was able to surround the
earth and grasp its own tail
at which time ragnarok would begin the
serpent's arch enemy
is thor thor ultimately killing it these
clues help us see where these storylines
could take us in future seasons in
mythology it's never really explained
how loki gave birth to the snake
but in the show the snake is surgically
removed after being diagnosed as a
tapeworm in lawrence just how loritz
came to acquire this tapeworm is also
not known however we do know it started
to grow
shortly after he had his outing with
vidar in which he ate a raw reindeer
heart and was shown his healing powers
the final episode is titled all you need
is love the line lord says to magna
after being convinced magnus using the
key for love
the irony here is that it's magna's love
for his brother not
cygni that is making him forge the
hammer magda is able to successfully
forge it and escape
running home just in time for his 18th
birthday
he tries throwing it just like he did in
season one but his powers have not
returned
meanwhile iman and halva are fired from
their jobs at the troll garden nursing
home where voton is a patient he and the
other patients give them a rousing
send-off of yes we love this country
which is the norwegian national anthem
and same song that played in the last
episode of season 1.
tour does magna to gather lords's
laundry where he discovers lords has
been keeping this snake
it's kind of interesting since if the
show follows the mythology it will be
him who eventually kills it lawrence
picks up burgers for magna's birthday
where he finds out his love interest who
works at the diner is making
out with the epa officer it's just
another instance that showcases how
loritz is so
alone by the end of the season he'll
have been betrayed by his brother
ostracized by the giants and heartbroken
by his crush this sets up his character
to be one who only cares about himself
over the past few episodes magna has
been struggling with a paper on norse
mythology and eventually asked the
question
tusha
a classic what came first the chicken or
the egg when it starts to thunder
magnus hammer begins to rumble
which is coincidentally the same line i
say to my romantic partners
unlike a few episodes ago magna has
embraced who he is the chosen one and
only when he realizes this do his powers
come back to him
lawrence does not approve believing that
magna's betrayal and forging of the
hammer brings him
one step closer to killing him
ron and fiore punished saxa after all it
could only have been her key that opened
the warehouse
this beating along with her ousting as
president of util will see her
allegiance
shift with his powers back magna heads
to the utils where he'll find
saxa beaten up and in one of the
strangest turns of the season
saxa offers an alliance of sorts saying
that the two of them together could rule
everything she'd be able to take over
yutal and he'd be able to kill ran and
fiore she then attempts to grab magnus
hammer before
grabbing his other hammer yes saxa and
magna make love i personally felt this
turn
wasn't quite earned in the show but i
can see what the writers were trying to
do here because
in norse mythology saxa is a lover of
thor
and ends up birthing two of his sons
modi and magni
she never becomes thor's monogamous
lover so expect a lot of drama to come
out of this relationship in season 3.
after they do have sex magna remarks how
it doesn't feel right and that's
probably because gods and giants are
arch enemies
and this isn't supposed to happen
meanwhile ran and fiore try to kill
loritz they believe he gave the key to
magna to forge the weapon that could
kill them
however they don't know that loritz was
tricked into this and just when it looks
like
lords will be a goner lord says he has
the one thing that can destroy magna for
good he's of course referring to the
world serpent they watch him release at
the end of the episode
magna arrives and uses his sick hammer
to chase off ren and fjor
he asks for lords's forgiveness which we
never get an
answer and in the final scene of the
season lords unleashes the rapidly
growing snake into the fjord as ran and
fiore watch on
the final shot being of lortz's amber
and blue eyes
signifying his half god half giant blood
now there's currently no word if
ragnarok has been greenlit for season 3
but it's clear season 2 has set up a ton
of potential storylines will gree come
back from the city will there be a time
jump how will the utils gain the upper
hand
and whose side will loki eventually
gravitate towards
i want to hear all your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching everyone please make sure
to like and subscribe it really means a
lot for me in the channel and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much